foreign
if you're looking for tips and tricks on
publishing with Pub sub then you're in
the right place hi I'm Chloe and in this
video I'll be sharing six best practices
when publishing with Pub sub let's get
started
number one batch messages
by batching messages you can increase
throughput but larger batches also mean
increased latency depending on your
number of Publishers in combination with
flow control and batch settings you'll
be able to make decisions around the
right optimizations for your specific
usage your goal should be to consider
the message size and publisher
throughput to optimize for cost and
latency check out links in the
description below for a blog post with
more information number two be mindful
when using ordering keys
publishing messages with an ordering key
might slightly increase end-to-end
message delivery latency since Cloud Pub
sub takes steps to coordinate the
storage and delivery of messages across
different servers when using ordered
delivery generally speaking when you
want to optimize for latency you should
enable batching since the client will
wait for the batch to fill up before
sending the batch to Cloud Pub sub
however with ordering Keys If a batch of
messages fails to publish they will be
retried and can mess up the publish
order we recommend when you publish with
ordering Keys you disable batching that
is set batch settings to allow only a
single message to ensure messages are
published in order one by one publish
the next message only when the previous
one has been successfully received by
the pub sub server number three use a
regional endpoint
another must do when publishing with
ordering Keys is to use a regional
endpoint
since order delivery is only guaranteed
within a region using a regional
endpoint instead of a global endpoint to
publish messages to the same region can
be especially useful number four
consider bandwidth
your published throughput is constrained
by your network bandwidth as well as the
number of requests you are sending if
your bandwidth is good but your network
latency is high you don't want to
overwhelm the system with too many small
requests
you can also use publisher side flow
control to help with client-side network
issues
number five provision your publishers
your published throughput is also CPU
and memory bound more available machine
cores allow you to set higher thread
count for better published throughput to
learn more about how to maximize
streaming performance check out our
links in the description for a blog post
that dives deeper into this topic and
number six customize your own default
retry settings
when publish request timeout you will
get deadline exceeded errors these are
automatically retried by the client
libraries but you can tweak the default
retry settings with different initial
timeout retry multiplier and total
timeout values
check out the pub sub documentation to
learn more about recommended initial
deadline and total timeout
there you have it six best practices for
publishing with Pub sub thanks for
joining and keep an eye out for more
best practice videos and take a look at
our Pub sub documentation for even more
tips and tricks for publishing with Pub
sub
foreign